absolument media oberus ladies and
gentlemen whoo so I feel like you
already own this mass before Corona hit
this is my baby
what have you been doing in the meantime
over this quarantine I've been playing
NBA 2k man I'm become a professional NBA
2k player I haven't I haven't slept in
in 80 hours this is the life now I do
this [ __ ] a member two weeks I'm
honored that you got a you gotta be
willing nuff but when they Zig you zag
when they zag music this is how I live
now da what I do now a movie you don't
have any type of sitcom in your head no
sketch you just now I play video games
see look that's my character right there
look at he's doing his thing he's
chilling he installed a shop where is he
yeah I'm about to buy some clothes
what does the game let you just shop
what happened to just playing basketball
see that's why they got it you got to
have outfits practice you grind you see
late nights in the gym early mornings in
a gym and then one day I'm gonna be
there right and it's gonna happen by the
time they should happen the next NBA 2k
don't drop you have to do it all over
again I'm up for the challenge Rory this
sin Roy this is serious so as I go on
this journey I need your support not
your judgment in this NBA 2k life
because it is not easy lights have you
taken a bath yet in quarantine because
you sound like a [ __ ] tank take a bath
but the fire bad eye balls and underarms
this is a man this is a gig it doesn't
if if I'm gonna really grind this player
that's waste of time any time spent
showering could be spent getting my
player to a ninety nine rating overall
and so once I get that night when I go
to the park when I'm at the park
it's crazy man so long we out here so
you are not handling quarantine will is
what I'm understanding I think I'm
handling quarantine perfectly I don't do
that you're not handle in quarantine
handling quarantine wonderfully I've
been a nice tuxedo jacket in living room
I'm drinking with you wearing an event
blazer that's your computer but you
ain't bathe your house your house is
like digging balls
prove it prove it prove it is silent
circulation in here can people know you
just jealous if somebody does look at
this
look II just elbow got a DJ set into why
is interest elbow alright I'm a media